how did yanukovych find you
through this oligarch through this
oligarch so did you work with the
oligarch in russia first or did you
well this is a ukrainian old guard
ukrainian because you also work with a
oligarch in russia what happened was
i worked for oligar derapasco right it
was an it was an oligarch and who is he
exactly he's the aluminum king he's
number two largest aluminum uh company
in the world
russia
he's from russia yeah he's a russian
oligarch
he had plants
all over the world i mean natural
resources that were needed for aluminum
and things like that
and uh and he hired me to help him
actually
involve get involved in elections in
this country was that what year was that
this was probably 2005 yeah it was too
high so that's way before so you
and he was in russia at the time when
you were working with him he was in
russia at the time but my work for him
was not in russia my work for him was in
the countries in africa and in
ukraine where he had plans
and where uh he needed help
two types of help number one
protecting his interests by having
me help build a live lobbying strategy
and public affairs strategy firm because
a lot of these countries were either
dictatorships whereas culture or former
parts of the soviet union uh in in the
stand countries like kazakhstan turkish
menace and ukraine
and so i was helping him build a
and running election swarm into some of
the democratic countries in in africa
like guinea um
and
in the course of that he said you want
to get involved in ukraine because
they're talking about nationalizing one
of my plants down there in the in this
pro-western government that's supposed
to be against this kind of stuff and so
i went down and i looked and i started
getting involved that's how i interacted
with aiken gum
and that's how i then was introduced to
renat akhmatov who was the ukrainian
oligarch who was having his countries
nationalized as well
and uh
and it was because of that
that as i was helping him akhmatov said
to me
would you ever think of running helping
us you know with an election here in the
united in ukraine i said well it's going
to depend i mean
who am i going to help you with what's
it going to be all about and he said
look take a poll see what i mean you
know our interest now because i've
gotten to know the some of the political
interests figure out what we need to do
and so i did and
in the party of regents which was the
party of the eastern ukrainians and the
you know and that had been discredited
in the 2004 elections
what i saw in that first poll was that
the party wasn't really discredited as
much as demoralized america there was
support for the party in eastern ukraine
it was a regional support i mean you
just like you have red states and blue
states uh here in the united states in
ukraine you had
uh uh russian you know ethnic states or
old bliss as they call them and and
western oriented obelisk
the western part of the country
uh and so it became a red blue kind of
uh breakdown in the the
typical to what you see here in the
united states they didn't talk to each
other they talked over each other they
didn't listen to each other but what i
found was that the eastern part think as
i said a few minutes ago
they did not want they they did not want
to be part of russia they needed they
wanted to protect their interests the
party of regents protected their
interests because it was from the it was
from the eastern part yanukovych was the
governor of donetsk before he ran for
president uh donuts being the one of the
the biggest obelisk
in the east
and uh they saw him
as a loser and there was some
controversy whether he tried to steal
the election some people say shanko
tried i wasn't involved i i never got
involved in that issue uh i made it a
point that whatever a campaign i was
going to be involved in we were going to
have an electric election integrity
component and work with all of the
international organizations to bring
them in to watch the elections and
ballot security and every one of the
elections i was a part of there was a
major component of it where i actually
had a part of my staff dealing directly
with the european union on election
integrity and facilitating the
international observers coming in to
watch the elections in all of the
potential places that were corrupt
you know what's crazy as i'm listening
with paul
this guy's a ukraine expert
i mean
you know don't judge a book by its cover
you know there's a lot of people
especially on the left they're like oh
he's just corrupt
russian
you know pawn like this guy's been
dealing with ukrainian politics for two
decades and he's breaking it all down
i'm trying to follow what's going on
ukrainian politics how many americans
literally know as much about ukrainian
politics as you no
zero like you're an expert on this i'm
the expert on the expert on ukrainian
politics including with the u.s state
department as well by the way that's
what i'm saying here i feel like he
could be utilized and not scrutinized uh
that he's been by the media but but it
doesn't it's not convenient i mean there
are to quote al gore inconvenient truths
and the inconvenient truth is that they
would have to acknowledge that it isn't
black and white right yeah you know one
of the biggest problems for yanukovich
and the reason i think he fled
was something that i was came
but they were all corrupt yeah i mean
for if you just say you can't be free
and cool but you have to be for x
x was just as corrupt zelinski is also
no i know
is a different model
i mean there's a
zielinski represents
an emergence of ukraine from
the shadows of the ukrainian of your of
soviet uh influence i mean he's a new
style politician he doesn't come out of
politics he hasn't he hasn't been
corrupted on the way up now there are
people who say well he's owned by one of
the oligarchs uh who is corrupt but it's
almost by necessity right like he was
doing his thing whatever but now when
putin invades he's got no other options
when did you realize yanukovych was
corrupt well i mean
i i didn't know how corrupt till it was
over
um
and but it would show up in my polls i
mean there was corruption that was going
on and
barissimo was one of the corrupt
companies
that that i was
wailing against that you you've got to
you know bring the light onto all of
this stuff and uh
and
and barisswa
was managed by corrupt
yanukovych people who were partners of
hunter biden so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you